one of the latest projects I'm doing is
Farm beats and for that to actually see
how well your research works you need to
be out there in a farm and a lot of
times when I'm going there it's raining
out here in Seattle then like what am i
doing going out there in the farm in the
middle of nowhere in this rain but on
the other hand just reminding yourself
that if this research works this is
going to benefit so many farmers gives
you that level of energy to keep going
to keep thinking about doing bigger
things and not stopping where you are
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes Inga when
we think about artificial intelligence
and the world of the future our vision
is usually more Jetsons than Green Acres
but for dr. Ranveer Chandra a principal
researcher in the systems and networking
group at Microsoft Research rural farms
are the perfect place to realize the
benefits of AI through what he calls
precision agriculture or data-driven
farming today in a wide-ranging
interview dr. Chandra talks about how
his research may eventually make your
Wi-Fi signal stronger and your battery
life longer but also shares the story of
how spending childhood summers with his
grandparents in rural India inspired a
line of research that could change the
face of farming and help meet the food
and nutrition needs of a growing global
population that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Ranvir Chandra welcome to the podcast
it's great to see you today yeah thank
you I'm excited to be here so you're a
principal researcher in systems and
networking and it says on the website
that you develop technologies that
expand the state-of-the-art in computing
that's a pretty broad statement what
does it mean I come from a networking
background I do computer networking the
innovations that can help you connect
devices better that's what my PhD was
and my PhD was on technology called
virtual Wi-Fi since 2009-2010 I've
started expanding the scope of what I do
from networking to other technologies as
well for example batteries and improving
the battery life of devices and more
recently to farms in some sense they are
all about systems they're all about how
do you make technology better more
accessible how can you take a big step
in the different systems components be
it networking be it operating systems be
batteries be it the Internet of Things
how do you connect devices to the
Internet and coming up with technologies
that take the state of the art to the
next level and with each one of them
that's what we are trying to accomplish
yeah and having experienced technology
for decades now I understand the
connectivity networking making
everything work together is one of the
biggest challenges because you've got
people all over the world coming up with
new ideas and how do you connect them
all yeah yeah and just to put that point
in perspective they don't half the world
is still not connected to the Internet
right and that's what drives this point
even more that we need innovations we
need to come up with new technologies to
get everyone connected to bring the
benefits of technology to everyone right
to democratize technology yeah yeah
Ranvir you're a busy guy you have
multiple research projects on the go
you've published more than 80 academic
papers that have been cited multiple
times and you've got more than 85
patents
and you're active in the larger research
community you're serving on committees
you've got projects initiatives awards
media mentoring advising pH I mean
seriously let's get go on what do you do
in your spare time
well whatever time I get I like thinking
about the research problems the open
crumbs that's what gives me the energy
to keep going on everything else I do
like doing all the work you just
mentioned like being involved with
students that gives me a lot of
excitement that makes me happy just
makes me think more about the research
that I do gives me new ideas working
with the younger community that's why I
serve on PhD committees I love talking
to students whenever they visit
University I asked my host to set up at
least one hour talking to graduate
students Wow so this is something that
excites me same with in the research
community I'd like serving on program
committees because it keeps me up to
date with what's going on and thinking
about new ideas but in the spare time
yeah I like thinking about these
research problems I do have a wife and a
daughter and I'd like my family we like
doing things together as well usually on
the weekends but on weekdays yeah it's a
busy schedule
yeah it's work and also working with
different parts of the world we work
with India with China so it takes up
nearly all our yeah time during the week
but it's exciting I'm not complaining
it's something that I like doing well
what's funny was that I was going to ask
the follow-up question seriously what
inspires you and how do you sustain this
level of work and you've just answered
that one what are you doing your spare
time because that is what you do for joy
yeah sounds like yeah in the sense I
really like my work I'm really excited
to come to work every day even I travel
a lot but even when I'm traveling I
don't complain I really like doing
research and thinking about these
meeting students like I'll give you an
example one of the latest projects I'm
doing is Farm beats and for that to
actually see how well your research
works you need to be out there in a farm
try a research so we work with Shan
Stratman who's a smallholder farmer
incarnation which is 25 miles east of
here and a lot of times and I'm going
there it's reading out here in Seattle
I'm like what am i doing going out there
in the farm in
middle of nowhere in this rain but on
the other hand just reminding yourself
that if this research works this is
going to benefit Sean but if it's so
many farmers gives you that level of
energy to keep going to keep thinking
about doing bigger things and not
stopping where you are well let's talk
about some of the specific projects
you're working on we just started sort
of there but one that really interested
me was this TV whitespace dynamic
spectrum spectrum opportunity program
that you're doing called white space
networking project so what kind of
things can you do with spare spectrum so
to speak and why is it important so to
give you an idea of what the TV white
spaces can enable is imagine if you go
to Best Buy you buy a Wi-Fi router and
you plug it into your house imagine if a
future router of this kind you could
access the internet a few miles away
right now as soon as you exit your house
your Wi-Fi is disappears so the way we
do that this was work we did back in
2009 this was the best paper at ACM
PSICOM the particular technology that we
had developed here was a way to take a
Wi-Fi signal and put it in an empty TV
channel what we mean by that says this
is over-the-air TV the TV you watch
using antennas so you know when you
browse over-the-air TV you see certain
channels here on channel 7 you're
getting a TV broadcast on channel 8 all
you see is white noise she's nothing
coming there the particular technology
we developed was a way to put a Wi-Fi
signal in that noise channel such that
it doesn't interfere with your TV
reception on an adjacent channel so you
could be watching channel 7 on channel 8
we could be sending Wi-Fi and the reason
this is so cool is that compared to
Wi-Fi at the same power level typically
in UHF TV frequencies your signals will
go 4 times father-in VHF they will go 12
times father and this is in free space
just purely based on physics if you put
trees crops canopies buildings your
signals propagate even more in fact in
some of our experiments in India where
we connected a rural high school to the
internet our non line-of-sight link was
10 miles at 16 kilometers we were able
to stretch the internet by 16 kilometers
to that High School which previously
didn't have
any internet connection before so that's
what the TV white spaces enables it
enables you to send Wi-Fi signals over
much longer distances and there's a lot
of technology behind that if you go to
our web site you'll find lots and lots
of papers that we've written on it but
the FCC Chairman was here in 2010 in
this building and we showed him this
demo at that time and since then this
technology has been made legal in the US
and right now it's legal in several
other countries as well can you just
grab it I mean you don't have to go
through any channels to apply for it or
any no so this is where a lot of the
technology pieces were developed there's
a the concept that at that time was
proposed what's called dynamic spectrum
access and now there's an alliance and
we have proposed an architecture where
you have a web service in the background
your device would say this is where I am
the web service would reply and say at
this location these are the channels you
can use so that's a new way to establish
an internet connection but with that we
had shown that you can establish these
connections in a way that doesn't
interfere with the TV reception so right
now there is a big momentum around this
there lots of companies involved in the
dynamic spectrum access alliance I'll be
giving a keynote at their conference in
London in May this year and there is an
entire ecosystem around the TV white
spaces new devices are getting built the
vision here is to be able to get the
internet access to the remotest places
in the world
and some of the messages you get from
people like students in Africa sending a
small message saying thank you so much
for this work we were able to access the
internet for the first time these are
really touching messages which we think
we're still not there with this research
we've made the first steps of connecting
people but that's the vision we want to
use this technology to get Internet in
the hands of everyone you know there's a
text acronym s MH have you heard of it
No called shaking my head and every
single podcast I'm shaking my head going
I cannot believe this is so interesting
so exciting and so useful right yeah I
mean yeah so at some point can I just
get extra whitespace if I want Wi-Fi
while I'm driving
because I've always mad when I leave my
house at some point will it be yeah
anyone yeah so one of the things that
happened since we did this work in 2009
the paper that we had written was called
white 5 for Wi-Fi over the white spaces
so we would expect that in the future
you would have these like right now on
your phone you have a two 2.11 EBG you
could have there's an I Triple E a two
2.11 standard 802 11 AF which is also
known as the white Phi standard then
that is about taking the Wi-Fi standard
and using it in the TV white spaces so
in the future who knows this could be
something that could be very real
[Music]
another area I was surprised to learn
about was battery research and you've
referred to it a couple of times not
something I would have expected be going
on in Microsoft research for some reason
but tell us what's going on in battery
research from your perspective and it's
gonna make our lives better yes I
already think of ten reasons yeah so we
started this research back in 2010 where
I'm leading this battery research across
Microsoft where it's not just about
research we work with the product teams
as well and we are looking at ways in
which you can improve the battery life
of mobile devices take you to the next
level our mission is to keep working on
this until you can get your devices to
last a week without charge and we're
thinking of mobile devices mobile
devices could be phones laptops tablets
two-in-ones
any of these and we're taking a holistic
approach working all across the battery
stack from batteries itself to how these
batteries are managed in the hardware to
the device drivers to the operating
system to the applications all
throughout and coming up with ways in
which we can take it to the next level
to improve battery life and one of the
things we did initially was to come up
with a way to model the battery
consumption of the devices how much
power does your display use as your
processor used as your network use we
built models for all of the
and then we worked very closely with the
different product teams on transferring
the technology and they're part of the
research that we do all the teams within
Microsoft one of the key technologies is
Software Defined batteries and we're
super excited about that that's a new
paradigm of the way you use batteries
what we came up with was a way in which
you can combine batteries of different
chemistry's you can imagine a
fast-charging battery and a high energy
density battery plugged together and
with a little bit of hardware what we
did was you could switch across the
different batteries and this is kind of
the entire stack that we build all the
way from batteries the battery hardware
and the operating system module and the
AI piece at the artificial intelligence
piece of predicting what kind of
workload is going to come and based on
that we came up with this paradigm of
software-defined batteries based on
which we showed that you can mix and
match different batteries so we did the
first step with that of showing it on
mobile devices but the real passion
behind this comes from being able to use
it in the grid if you think of the
electric grid or even electric vehicles
one of the biggest challenges there is
how long is it going to last
how much farther can you go on one
charge same with the electric grid how
much charge can you store and until now
everyone still uses batteries of the
same chemistry we believe with this
paradigm which we developed a while back
the first time this idea came to us was
in 2011 and since then we kept modifying
the technology before we published it in
2015 this was chosen as one of the
research highlights in C ACM the
communications of the ACM in 2016 and
now we are thinking of broadening the
scope of what we had developed to see
where else can it be used and you can
imagine others in a like I mentioned
electric vehicles right so whenever you
sit in a car if you enter your GPS
coordinates or even if you could learn
that you know what now I'm going home
you know what kind of traffic it's going
to hit what kind of temperature it's
going to be whether you going to be
breaking a lot all these things affect
your battery consumption so then based
on where you're going the prediction
part is easier you can easily build the
smarts in so that your car can go that
extra bit longer right by pulling from a
different by putting from different
batteries based on your profile
based on what the traffic is be somewhat
the read it is and so this is one of
those podcasts where it's like
everything you say I can see how it can
impact my life that's where you are oh
let's go a little bit more I could talk
to you about batteries for an hour
seriously and that's kind of weird for
me I usually talk about batteries two
people one of the most well known
projects you're leading is an incubation
on IOT applications called farm beats
you referred to it earlier but it's
really cool I want to know more about it
I know our listeners would like to know
more about it so tell us about farm
beats yes yeah I'm super excited about
it I've been doing this for about three
years now so the reason I started this
project is I don't have an agricultural
background and I'm not a farmer one of
those things on your resume I know so my
PhD is in computer science but I did
have some experience with farming in the
sense that when I was growing up in
India as it happens in India every
summer and winter vacation you have to
spend with your grandparents
and my grandparents lived in a farm in a
small village in Bihar it's in rural
India and every summer and winter
vacation such three months of summer
vacation and one month of winter
vacation I would be spending there with
them and they used to hate that because
as it was at that time in the farms in
India the villages they didn't have any
electricity no bathrooms
it wasn't easy living and there's a time
I was in a city so I didn't like it but
I still went there I spent a lot of time
there a lot of my friends were in the
villages
I learned biking when I was there with
those friends because they had to go to
yeah yeah yeah and so exactly so but
then I think in a way that I didn't like
farming then but in a way it's kind of
giving back I having seen the poverty
the kind of the way people go about
doing farming I want to develop
technologies that can impact their lives
the goal of farm bates is to enable
data-driven farming so just to give you
a bit of perspective the world's food
production needs to increase by about 70
percent by 2050 to feed the growing
population of the world and I will set
another meeting
different people and there's a lady from
the Rockefeller Foundation and she
mentioned that you know what we're
talking of 70% to feed the world but
what about nourishing the world the
challenge is even more giving them
nutritious food good food
yeah good food so how do we get there so
it's like the Green Revolution all over
again because we need to meet this food
production demand without an increase in
the amount of arable land the amount of
arable land is about the same the water
levels are receding the challenge is
even more we will need to get there in a
sustainable way
so agricultural scientists have been
thinking about this problem and the most
promising technique seems to be that of
data-driven farming what we mean by
data-driven farming is the ability to
map a farm and overlay it with data for
example what is my soil moisture level
six inches below the soil what is my
soil nutrient level throughout the farm
if you can build maps like those that
can enable techniques such as precision
agriculture right what we mean by
precision agriculture is the ability to
do site-specific applications for
example rather than putting water
uniformly throughout the farm you apply
it only where it is needed instead of
spraying pesticides on the farm you
apply it only where there are pests
precision agriculture has been shown to
improve yield reduce cost it's also
better for the environment yeah and once
you can build maps like this the other
benefit that we got approached by some
other companies which are like we could
use this to improve seed phenotypes it's
not only about precision agriculture it
could also help with phenotyping which
can help feed the world precision
agriculture was proposed back in the 80s
that technique it still hasn't taken off
30 years down the line and one of the
main reasons it hasn't taken off is
because of the cost of data-driven
agriculture solutions just to give you
an idea there was an expo that I had
attended where there were lots of
companies presenting the precision
agriculture equipment and the cheapest
sensors are that Expo were five sensors
for $8,000 and a recurring cost for a
farmer who doesn't make that much money
most of them to invest in that kind of
an infrastructure without knowing what
the ROI the return on investment is is
asking for too much yeah so the goal of
the farm beets project is to bring down
the cost of these data driven
agriculture solutions by two orders of
magnitude we want to bring it down from
8,000 to 80
and this is the goal and we have some
innovations based on which we think we
can get there is there any connection to
the white space a project and far meets
project yeah so one of the key reasons
these existing sensors are expensive is
because of the cost of connecting these
sensors to the cloud imagine if you're
out in the middle of the farm a lot of
times you'll end up using satellite
connectivity to connect them or custom
cellular because a lot of times you
don't get cellular connectivity you'll
build your own base stations so the key
insight in the context of agriculture
was that TV towers are where people are
in cities and Seattle you have a lot of
TV towers across the lake the farms are
away from the cities there are fewer
people in the farms because there are
fewer people in the farms you have fewer
TV towers what that means is you have a
lot of empty TV channels what that means
is you have a lot of spectrum we are
talking of hundreds of megabits of
unused capacity at which point we are
not only connecting sensors we could be
connecting drones cameras streaming a
lot of data from the middle of the farm
that you previously couldn't gather our
vision is this like Wi-Fi connects your
house a TV white spaces can be used to
connect the farm and in our deployments
that's what we do we set up this antenna
in the farm and miles around it now gets
connected you could be streaming data
from the middle of nowhere if you talk
to actually cultural scientists the
number one problem they face is that of
getting data yeah so that's one of the
innovations the second thing we did was
so right now if you wanted to build an
accurate map what is the soil moisture
level six inches below the soil
throughout my farm well because soil
moisture varies a lot you would say you
know what I'll deploy lots and lots of
sensors but deploying a lot of sensors
is expensive to deploy to manage it also
comes in the way of the farmer as a
farmer designated a job so then the key
innovation we came up with was a way to
build this map using very few sensors
and the way we do that is we combined
ground sensor data with a telemetry for
example using these UAVs the drones
see you fly a drone get the visual image
we take that to train a machine learning
model all using the ground sensor data
and then we use that with very few
sensors we're able to build very
accurate maps off the farm so using the
TV white spaces it brings down the cost
of the sensors
using this technology of fusing aerial
imagery with drones
we need much fewer sensors than what you
needed earlier in the startup space or
even in research you see a lot of people
working on drones a lot of people
working on sensors we believe we are the
first who's been able to combine both of
them in a meaningful way we did that for
soil moisture soil temperature and soil
pH once we presented it to other
companies they want to use it for many
other use cases they think the
technology can now be used for many
other applications in farming the other
innovation we came up with it was with
the white spaces we can gather a lot of
data you can send a lot of data from the
drones from the cameras you can be
putting these cameras in barns
monitoring cows you can send all that
data to the farmers house but the
farmers house doesn't have great
connectivity to the internet so what we
did was our key insight was that most
farmers have pcs if they don't have a PC
we shipped them an azure IOT edge device
this sits on the farm and this does a
lot of compute lot of machine learning
sitting on the farm itself it can be
available offline and so on and only
sends the summaries to the cloud and the
fourth innovation we had was around
power we're in Seattle if I'm using
solar panels you need to come up with an
innovation around power especially
inventor when you don't get a lot of Sun
how do you get your system running so we
had some innovations there as well but
this is the complete package of things
that we call farm beats variable to
gather a lot of data using the white
faces and then apply new machine
learning on top of it using the
technologies I mentioned to come up with
insights yeah this is going to be called
the SMH podcast because I even did
background research but on you this is
fascinating and fantastic do you have to
get the cows permission to monitor that
that's a good question we at least get
the farmers permission we're gonna watch
your cows I know it's for they don't go
via their own safety I know and health
and we can tell when a cow is sick and
things say yeah yeah like a nursery
monitor it's the kid crying it's the kid
okay
[Music]
let's talk a little bit about this is
I'm having so much fun here and all I'm
doing is listening let's talk about tech
transfer which is kind of a broad term
in the industry it's probably the goal
of most researchers to see but you
described earlier your passion to see
your work have an impact on other
people's lives but you have a lot of
stuff going on that's tech transfer is
that part of your DNA with your work
here in systems and networking
yeah and that was one of the reasons I
had joined Microsoft research in the
first place and when I graduated from
Cornell in 2005 all other places I had
interviewed in were academic positions
this was the only industry Lava had
considered and the reason I wanted to
come here is because I've wanted to ship
technology that touches people that is
in the hands of people and Microsoft
gives a really good vehicle to do that
it and its technology is used everywhere
anything you develop if you can do a
transfer to the products your technology
will reach out to so many people the
impact you create is huge which as an
academic is difficult it's not
impossible but much more difficult here
it should be easier and yeah so with
nearly all the projects I have worked
very closely with product teams of the
batteries with virtual Wi-Fi with white
spaces with farm beats so going back to
your question I do enjoy technology
transfers I enjoy working with the
product teams the engineers the added
realism to your research where in
research we are allowed to think while
to think way ahead in the future of
things that anyone else if you didn't
even L say it's not possible you can go
target that question and the engineers
help you stay grounded at the same time
that is here you can come up with a
wacky idea but how do you take it to the
real world it is something which I think
being at Microsoft that's an edge that
you get while being here you are in
proximity to so many other researchers
you're in proximity to the engineers to
the sales team who actually talk to
customers and you go talk to customers
as well so that's one of the
Trane's one of the benefits of working
at Microsoft Research I love this so
much I've got a Venn diagram going in my
mind of interdisciplinary research
efforts you know across different fields
that you get here and then you've got
the transfer into the product groups I
mean I've heard actually recently that
there's researchers that end up in
product groups and I'd call them human
text transfer yeah but it's just sort of
this dynamic flow of ideas in exchange
and I love the fact that you're saying
hey how does this impact a customer even
from a research perspective
ya know over here you get a holistic
view and having been here at Microsoft
for 13 years now it adds a new
perspective like for example with farm
beats it's a project and our
collaborators are from computer vision
machine learning hardware agriculture
audio networking systems batteries you
touch every possible research and then
you come up with something and then you
talk to customers you further tweak your
research in a way that can then actually
transfer to the products as well you're
not just writing papers here at
Microsoft which is exciting yeah even
though the papers are fun yeah right
yeah Harry Shum refers to what he calls
an invisible revolution it's the system
that becomes transparent and you just
have an experience with the technology
without knowing what's your take on the
invisible revolution for technology yeah
I think it's absolutely needed and
that's something where I'm trying to
push on that through my research as well
for example at farm be sticking to it to
a farmer who might not even be
tech-savvy most of them are not and
helping them benefit from all the latest
advances in computer vision machine
learning networking systems all of that
bringing you to the farmer but to the
farmer they don't realize all the things
in the background that's making it
happen all they see is the benefits of
that technology doing core research is
important the other part is taking that
research in a way where it reaches
everyone it democratizes a technology
right it gets to everyone out there
and everyone can benefit from the
advances that you do and I think more
and more of it will happen so one of the
things I'm seeing here at Microsoft is a
breadth of projects that really
surprised me
how does this work at Microsoft that you
could do something in batteries you
could do something in functional
programming languages you could do
something in quantum you could do
something on a farm yeah no that's a
great question and this is something
which is the unique aspect of Microsoft
research and Microsoft and this is what
I doubt you'd get it anywhere else and a
lot of it is driven by a leadership from
Eric - Harry - sat there where
everyone's promoting this growth mindset
within Microsoft where you're coming to
Microsoft not just because you're doing
your job you're coming here because it
helps you fulfill a passion something
that you're excited about that's one of
the reasons I've been able to do
agriculture and it's not something I'm
doing on the side without anyone else
noticing everyone notices sat there
blogged about it
Hoddy talks about it so you see it at
every level of our leadership something
where within Microsoft there is this new
culture this new growth mindset where
our executives want us to take risks
want us to do something that has a
bigger meaning than just your day job
and this is what I think you can do at
Microsoft Research as well here we get a
lot of freedom we are able to think big
the people around you are super-smart
these are the best people in all the
different areas of computer science
Electrical Engineering in other fields
yeah that's the encouragement that we
get using which we are able to take
risks take things to a new level and
this is one thing where people who are
graduating I would definitely recommend
Microsoft to them about these unique
opportunities which I doubt you'll get
anywhere else
you know this whole podcast is an
inspiration to next generation I mean I
literally shaking my head what advice
kind of parting thoughts would you give
listeners that are interested in getting
into this what challenges lie ahead in
the field that you think the next bright
minds might need to tackle want to
tackle what lines of research are top of
mind right now
yeah so there's some lines of research
which are heart in the research
community some other threads of research
which I get excited about I'll talk
about the latter because I want more and
more people to work on those problems
and that has been the guiding force
behind my thread of research as well
about how can you make technology more
pervasive bring the benefits of
technology to many more people who are
disadvantaged right now one of the
statistics I had given earlier was
around half the world's population is
still not connected to the Internet
how can we get Internet to everyone
electricity that's one of the other big
problems in our lives right now so I'm
working on batteries and we'll start
working on the electric grid as well how
do you get more people online in a clean
way with farm beats we're looking at the
agriculture problem how do we feed the
world bring the benefits of all the
technology that we are developing to the
rest of the population
just an advice to the audience listening
to this if you expand the scope of your
research to have an element that touches
humans it gives you a different
perspective around your research your
energy levels don't go down it gives an
amazing amount of satisfaction working
on these problems and this is one thing
I have seen even with working with my
interns initially a lot of them all of
them brilliant like the best minds from
all the top universities initially all
of them were working here sitting in the
lab but the people once they go out once
you see them going out and talking to
farmers doing this for like one of the
interns he was from Harvard he was doing
the TV white spaces project he was so
motivated by this work that he went out
over the weekend he drove 1,500 miles
stopping every six miles to measure what
is the signal standard and he got pulled
over by the cops a few times we don't
make all our interns do this it's
something he did and he does even and
the reason he was doing this is because
of the impact that this technology could
create since then once this technology
has been made legal we've connected so
many people in rural parts of Africa
India to the internet using this
technology same with interns here who
worked in farmers they just love going
to the farm and a lot of times without
telling me the excitement that they get
by having the research touch so many
lives is amazing and that's one of the
advice I would give is it's important to
do core research that sis go deeper and
expand the state-of-the-art in computer
science in that particular field while
doing that you can also be making the
linkage with the end goal that how does
it benefit the world how does it benefit
humanity how does it benefit people how
can I make technology more accessible to
them so that their lives are better
around there Chandra you are using AI
for good and not for evil and it's been
an inspiration talking to you today
again this is the SM H interview thank
you so much for coming in thank you to
learn more about dr. Ranveer Chandra and
how AI may be coming to a farm near you
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]